bene tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
nuovo video sono fa vj
sono io che mi sembra che sia passato
un secolo e mezzo dall'ultima volta che
ho fatto buoni premere il tasto che il
nome del gioco molto di pedrinate vuoi
premere il tasto praticamente il gioco
di dalle due opzioni e tu devi scegliere
se
accettarle entrambe o rifiutarne perché
puoi anche rifiutare tasto per rifiutare
e qua sotto cieli dito è nascosto però
va bene noi nel caso lo andremo a
cercare tipo in questo ottieni biglietti
d'altro e tradotto che google traduttore
non so se si vede ma si noterà le
persone vivono tranquilli ottieni
biglietti aerei gratuiti per il resto
della tua vita ma sai che un aereo a
caso che guidi si schianterà e pc da non
sono cosi pirla direi proprio di no per
una cagata del genere mi sembrava non
hai premuto il tasto e chicca premerebbe
stato tutti quelli a cui chiede di
uscire diranno di sì e non ti lasceranno
mai solo tu puoi scaricarli credo
intenda nelle relazioni va bene comunque
lasciare una persona è veramente una
merda io preferisco essere lasciato
prova niente guadagnerà istantaneamente
10 kg non appena gli chiede di uscire
può essere video 8 mar e due volte è
difficile normale non scompare se lasci
il tuo partner
io se prendo 10 chili non si vede niente
reso magrissimo qui potrei schiaccia c'è
paradossalmente la negatività per me la
positività e la positività per me la
lega di contrario è pazzesca sta roba
tutti qui però la prima
cerno mai diventi il migliore a
qualsiasi gioco online ma ritarda la
esili gallagher high occasionalmente
arrivando anche a più di mille bimbi
ma chi è che scrive schieti a vela
permessi perché se comunque diventò il
migliore nonostante il lago
vabbè che il caso e prega mai ma non
siete capaci meritate dilagare anche
giusto gioco porco demoni marte che se
siete migliore è un gioco fate sport
guadagnare un sacco di soldi ma
chiederei segna al business viene creata
nel nuovo afflusso di gioco perfetta
sotto ogni punto di vista e gratuita per
te non sarai mai in grado di utilizzare
del senato dispositivo per accesso a
internet
direi di no per cioè questo può ormai
ragazzi senza navigata già non so
guidare ci manca solo il navigatore non
funziona tutto bello ma anche no dai non
dovrai mai lavorare per il resto della
tua vita
più di fi loew super non scherza devi
sempre indossare i pannolini
e dopotutto rispettate che io mi diverto
faccio un lavoro che mi piace quindi
potrei farlo indossando un pannolino ma
sarebbe quello malus no nel mio caso no
poi vabbè ottieni tutta la musica
gratuitamente da internet che gli pagano
veronese con spotify stanzialmente le
spy kids becca dopo aver scaricato un
album dei michael burke e tutti sanno
che le scale o questa bellissima se
intelligente bello amato e apprezzato
modestamente io la nutella non esiste
mai non lo farò mai mai mai fate cagare
tutti puoi controllare i pensieri i
sentimenti nella singola persona questa
cosa orribile
ok questa cosa è orribile io non
riuscirei mai a fare questa cosa anche
se avessi questo potere punto perché mi
sentirei una barba mi venderà il
casualmente controllo il tuo corpo per
un'ora giorni qui in cui controlli
quella persona
non ho capito c'è questo vuol dire che
mentre controlli qualcuno puoi andare in
piazza del duomo nudo cosparso di burro
no ottieni biglietti gratuiti per i
concerti la tua vita l'incontro è che
cercò video non ci sono i concerti come
deve dare uno spettacolo di justin
bieber e degli one direction tre volte
l'anno e ora con il suo problema della
sentire nei gesti viverne gli one
direction il problema qual è un oliva
direction forse sì se non sciolgono so
perché non di seguono credo si siano
sciolti ma non è tanto quello perché
sono 33 vuol dire che sei volte al
lancio io faccio un concerto
una volta ogni due mesi che due palle
così ci apre sci anche con tutto l'amore
per justin bieber
facebook scompare myspace si rianima
cazzo silvio dare veramente troppo
curioso di vedere cosa succede quindi si
scusa tanto non lo uso per non usare
facebook e myspace però puoi leggere nel
pensiero solo quando le persone pensano
male di te sei te che cazzo prego
scusami almeno se sto uscendo con
ragazzo sto capisco capisco se
effettivamente gli ha fregato cosa di me
con la tua vita finisce adesso mica chi
sarà il prof non senti dolore come se
improvvisamente piazzamento si rialzano
tutti gli animali possono parlare come
più nove pezzi ti prego sono tutti molto
fastidiosi e completi cretini
ti prego voglio troppo vedere l'animale
parlare no dai puoi usare il carburante
gratis per dieci anni e questo è un bel
deal devi crescere dieci bambini in una
volta e questo non è un grandissimo deal
puoi modellare il cambiamento che ha
forse diventare quello che voglio poi
sono trasformati nutrivano una lampada
un paio di scarpe uno zaino scarabeo è
un pollo decapitato posso decidere di
fare questa cosa quindi non è che lo
devo usare sempre qui si diventa una
lampada piacimento ma che vuoi ai
intelligenza e le risorse per diventare
tutto ciò che vuoi astronavi energie
finita con donazioni cipa la persona che
oggi avrà sempre il merito delle tue
invenzioni
ma che cazzo te ne frega
nessuno nella mia vita c'è le persone
hanno la propria vita vi verranno dati
10 merito alla ri e non è male devi
tornare lo 0,01 per cento
e che cosa c'è di negativo non so
capello da tutto il resto che ho
guadagnato nella mia vita dovuto quello
10 mar scrivi una serie di libri più
popolari più popolari di harry potter
le cronache del ghiaccio e del fuoco e
il signore degli anelli e vabbè messi
insieme la bibbia la bibbia
l'adattamento cinematografico è noto
come il peggiore mai realizzata ma che
cazzo me ne frega lo scritto il caso
cosa ve ne frega dell'allattamento ce
l'ho scritto io stancarsi del regista ma
scusa di 20 milionario non potrai mai
più mangiare il tuo cibo preferito
ragazzi facciamo le ultime tre va bene
potrei cucina con essere perfetti non
puoi più andare sì forno e
puoi diventare invisibile funziona solo
un minuto al giorno ma cosa me ne frega
di quanto punto c'è allora tutto quello
che tu puoi attivare anche se diventi
una mosca tanto decidi tu quando
attivarlo va bene tutto prendi quello
che viene al massimo la tv mai ma
assolutamente sia il tuo corpo perfetto
perché non lo è già tutti pensano che tu
sia orribile lamela in pensione da te
non me ne frega niente ma sono già
perfetto quindi non hai la possibilità
di teletrasportarsi in qualsiasi parte
del mondo puoi passare solo un anno lì e
non tornare mai più
e
cioè che io mi anche perché io vado in
un posto e poi non ci possono mai piu
tornare perché mi sono state trasportate
vabbè ma c'è nel senso
vado in posti dove so che poi non
tornerò mai più si al massimo ti ripeto
non lo attivo quindi sì non andrò mai in
giappone così ecco quello per ragazzi
spero che questo mio motto che non
facevo lo faresti che il bello mi
mancava un sacco lo farei un prestampato
comunque raga fatemi sapere se volete
altri video lo faresti perché si chiama
ci vediamo ragazzi in un prossimo video
iscriviti al canale cioè momento mi
piace ai quali sociali nota trascrizione
e noi come sempre ci vediamo
ad un prossimo singhiozzo bella ragazza
[Musica]